preliminary results from the national
electoral council placed opposition
candidate ciomara castro in the lead
though a final tally was far from
completed the news was enough to spark
celebrations in the streets of the city
[Music]
for the honduran people this represents
an awakening a peace a hope the people
are overwhelmed by so much wrongdoing
and misery over the past 12 years the
people needed to breathe the people have
woken up
earlier in the day eager voters queued
for their turn at the ballot box
and polling locations extended their
closing hours to allow everyone a chance
to cast a vote
many expressed a distrust of the
electoral system citing a disputed
general election four years ago when the
governing national party claimed victory
despite evidence of fraud
actually i feel a little bit nervous
because uh you know all the uncertainty
that has been going on throughout the
elections
uh left and right as always they're
fighting both to um to buy for their
power so i'm actually just uh i'm
actually quite happy just knowing that
i'm coming even though i'm coming late
here to where my phone call is
in the late hours on sunday opposition
leader siomara castro spoke to
supporters claiming victory over
national party candidate naziri as fura
we are going to form a government of
reconciliation in our country a
government of peace and a government of
justice
[Applause]
the
honduran general election took place
under one of the most polarized
political environments in recent memory
with many people worried that violence
could spill out into the streets the
mood at least for now is only that of
celebration
honduran election officials have also
said voter turnout is the highest since
the 1980s when the country returned to
democratic rule
manuel rapalo al jazeera tegucigalpa
honduras